rund 100 menschen haben sich in dem
afrikanischen staat wenn er mit dem
ebola virus infiziert 60 sind gestorben
behörden sprechen bereits von einer
epidemie es ist das schreckgespenst der
modernen zivilisation weltweit sterben
millionen menschen an einem aggressiven
tödlichen erreger genau so wie jetzt
fängt die katastrophe an
zunächst sterben nur ein paar dutzend
menschen war schon schlimm genug ist
aber der erreger ist aggressiv und
verbreitet sich in windeseile
der ebola virus ist ein erreger er tötet
die meisten menschen verbreitet sich
sehr schnell und es gibt keine
gegenmittel weder medikamente noch
impfstoffe findet ein solcher erreger
den weg aus dem ausbruchs gebiet dann
kann die konsequenz millionen tote
bedeuten
im fall des ebola-virus wird ein solcher
ausbruch als besonders verheerend
eingeschätzt der virus habe das
potenzial als super virus die menschheit
massiv zu dezimieren
und das kann eben im schlimmsten fall
millionen tote bedeuten
allerdings hat der ebola virus einen
entscheidenden vorteil er ist so
aggressiv dass seine opfer
bedauerlicherweise meist nicht weit
kommen sehr schnell tritt fieber auf und
es kommt zu blutung in allen bereichen
des körpers an denen die patienten waren
schnell sterben erreichen die
infizierten nicht die nächste großstadt
kann seine ausbreitung gut eingedämmt
werden allerdings bedarf das extrem
hoher sicherheitsvorkehrungen wir
vergessen schnell dass es super
epidemien schon öfter auf der erde gab
schon zwischen 500 und 800 nach christus
brachten die pest wahrscheinlich ein
viertel der bewohner europas um noch
schlimmer grassierte sie im mittelalter
und raffte als der schwarze tod zwischen
347 und 1353 ein drittel der
europäischen bevölkerung dahin damals
waren das 25 millionen
in manchen landstrichen starben 90
prozent der menschen
das erschreckende an der pest sie ist
genauso aggressiv und tödlich wie ebola
und hat sich trotzdem sehr schnell
verbreitet bei der pest befällt das
bakterium yersinia pestis den körper
meist nach einem flow bis in der folge
und führen diese bakterien zu einer
sepsis einer entzündung des ganzen
körpers mit der folge von inneren
blutungen und organversagen
weitgehend unbekannt sind die epidemien
die die indianer in nord und südamerika
zu einem großen teil vernichtet haben
eingeschleppt durch die ersten europäer
dezimierten sie die amerikanische
bevölkerung in mehreren wellen
wahrscheinlich um mindestens 80 prozent
vor der besiedlung der beiden kontinente
war nord und südamerika viel dichter
besiedelt es gab sogar größere städte
die siedler stießen dann aber auf ein
weitgehend entvölkert das land weil die
eingeschleppten krankheiten millionen
und abermillionen indianer getötet
hatten
die bison werden so vermutet man die wir
aus zahlreichen western canon zogen in
massen durch das land weil ihre hüter
nicht gestorben waren
wir wiegen uns in einer trügerischen
sicherheit wenn wir meinen dass uns das
nicht passieren kann
pest und masern und andere epidemien
sind erst ein paar hundert jahre her und
gegen ebola haben wir immer noch kein
mittel
es können aber auch andere erreger seien
die plötzlich auftauchen
es kann jahre dauern bis ein gegenmittel
gefunden wird in dieser zeit kann die
seuche bereits ein unglaubliches unheil
angerichtet haben
hinzu kommt dass sich solchen heute viel
schneller verbreiten als vor 500 jahren
durch die täglichen flugbewegungen würde
ein aggressiver erreger bienen stunden
jedes land der welt erreicht haben und
wir können nichts dagegen tun war der
schweinegrippe habe ich es selbst erlebt
obwohl in einem flugzeug aus spanien ein
infizierter patient an bord war durften
alle passagiere das flugzeug verlassen
erst dann wurde der passagier in
quarantäne genommen und von im
biologischen sicherheits anzügen
erschienen den ärzten abgeführt
die strengen sicherheitsvorkehrungen
waren überflüssig die restlichen
passagiere waren bereits unterwegs und
hätten im schlimmsten fall binnen tagen
ganz deutschland infiziert was meint ihr
droht uns schon bald die nächste
pandemie also eine weltweite epidemie
oder ist das alles nur wieder panikmache
diskutiert es in den kommentaren hier
klicken
also da oben für das letzte video big
bang theory urknall aufgedeckt links
übrigens auch unten in der video
beschreibung und hier gehts zum klick
zum blog unbedingt ansehen und hier
findet ihr das video also dort
fleischkonsum zerstört unseren planeten
ich freue mich riesig über ein abo ist
er kostenlos auf youtube und sage zum
schluss wie immer bis dann bleibt dran